The first statement is not correct.
High contrast, rather than low contrast, between text and
background is optimal for viewing data within a table.
The same is true if you plan to display values directly on your own graphic.
The second statement is true.
A sequential palette like this one,
would indicate lower amounts of sales and low levels of saturation, and
higher amounts of sales with more saturation in the green color.
This third statement isn't correct though.
Darker and brighter colors would work better for smaller data points.
If the points were large enough, pastels might be a good option.
But if you don't have too many points in a graphic,
you could also enlarge over the points to aid the viewer's perception.
And finally, this last statement is correct.
There's no value in using cylinders, lighting effects, or
drop shadows in your data visualizations.
All of these effects simply obscure the data.